said yeah yeah I I completely condemn
alhamdulillah so the father is not the
father is the father is no no sorry he
said the father was spiritually inside
the son I think okay he fell into
heresy so when Jesus said only the
father knows the hour is that including
Jesus uh yeah Jesus knows the hour okay
so can open up the chap the cont the
context of the chapter is about
Mark which Which chapter sorry Which
chapter Mark 11 or 10 no Mark 1332 Mark
Mark 13 32 so you don't even know the
chapter you said but I know the context
okay so so Wii said he was ask about
their judgment correct yeah what did he
say he said that the the English is that
he doesn't know the hour but the
original Greek says that it's not for
him to declare the hour okay has a
semantic ring no it doesn't say that
because that's is another lie that
people try to regardless
okay I can also say that Humanity Christ
doesn't
know father communicates the knowledge
to the son so watch this that's why
Islam is spreading
Christian he said as a human being not
the hour so Jesus as God Jes as God does
he know the hour Jesus Jesus knows the
hour no listen carefully he just as
human me if I'm wrong Jesus as as human
he does not if Jesus was merely a human
he wouldn't know but he was God the same
time yeah but since but since he is also
God the Father communicates that
knowledge his divinity therefore he
knows the hour his Humanity the word
incarnate knows the hour so so that's
what I'm saying to simplify for the
people that's you know Christianity
that's why people live in because we
have what does it mean I I I don't
understand the metaphysics no no no no I
don't understand what does it mean you
mean what does it mean you mean what
youan I said could could you no I'm
saying that I do understand here when a
two right hand here it comes from the me
both Allah's are blessed I still
understand he explained it he explain L
one more time one more time dishonest
and sincere clearly right is God blessed
or
not God blessed take care of
yourself what you mean is God blessed
God is God holy God is Holy everything
about him everything about him okay why
you me about the two Hand they're holy
blessed bless mean God always show
generosity okay so bless both them don't
cuz I know you're not sincere to be
honest but I'm going to show you yeah I
know you very well the fact you're part
of this team who are known to play with
words and everything I know you anyway
so let's go back to the point so you
said J as human to simplify it J had two
nature correct has one comp who has so
Jesus was God and a man same time
correct correct so which part of Jesus
was God and which part was human what do
you mean which part he was 100% God 100%
human Okay so which part was God and
which part human he was fully God and
human so he was fully human and God the
same time correct so he was fully
powerful and UNP powerful same time take
care of yourself you
need no no no I'm running I'm I'm
running I'm running
[Laughter]
is God powerful yes is UN powerful clear
you ask him he said God is
powerful they live in they live in the
world of
[Music]
oon the world